the trophy administration's relief
effort is a good news story how do I
know because acting homeland security
secretary Elaine Duke said it was it is
really a good news story in terms of our
ability to reach people and the limited
number of deaths that have taken place
in such a devastating hurricane it's a
good news story like the Berenstein
bears and the limited number of deaths
but not everyone got the good news story
memo like Carmen you lean crews the
mayor of San Juan which is Spanish for
Trump haters Berg well maybe from what
she's standing it's a good news story
when are you drinking from a creek it's
not a good news story but do you all
have food for a baby it's not a good
news story dammit this is not a good
news story
look look mayor I understand your
criticism you feel this way because
you're seeing it with your own two eyes
but try to have some perspective you
can't see the forest for the trees and
you can't see the trees because they've
been blown away by the hurricane take it
from someone who has a little bit of
distance in a series of tweets on
Saturday the president attacked San Juan
mayor Carmen Ewell and Cruz for quote
poor leadership ability suggesting
Democrats were telling her to be quote
nasty to Trump and he said the mayor and
other leaders on the island quote want
everything to be done for them yes you
want everything done for you like some
privilege real estate developer son the
president is doing the best he can
let's compare this to the 2010 Haiti
earthquake back then we took two days to
send 8,000 troops but with Puerto Rico
it's taken us eight days to send about
half that it proves that Trump is
committed to taking his time and getting
this right there could be no doubt Trump
is trying what do you want he's doing
his best he's had a rough week he was
clearly a bad week for the president
starting a culture war using NFL players
a loser on health care a loser on the
Alabama Senate primary a loser on
hurricane response in Puerto Rico
now Tom Price not a good week for
president Truong price is paying the
price pun intended
because it's a bad week for Trump
and Trump is so defensive he's so caught
up in his own ego Trump's ego is his
strength second only to his alpha
handshake and sassy nicknames but more
importantly his ego is our North Star
and it has suffered this past week
that's why now more than ever we
Americans need to pull together and
provide Trump ego relief president Trump
is underwater
his ego has lost power and people are
saying he may not get that power back
for months and now elected officials
like mayor Cruz are publicly criticizing
Trump you don't insult people when they
are suffering through a crisis that's
not how a leader acts the fact is Trump
needs to hear some good news but he's
isolated in the Oval Office Trump is an
island it's extremely difficult to
deliver the praise and approval he needs
for his ego to survive as Americans we
must look out for those in need and
given everything that happened this past
week it's pretty clear Donald Trump is
our neediest person what can we do good
news
relief efforts are already underway
let's head over to citizen journalist
Laura gray Laura oh you've been in
Washington DC camped out at a Relief
Center since this disaster began how's
the recovery going so far well things
are going well Jordan though a lot of
people are bringing unnecessary things
like clothes and canned foods which I
keep screaming at them as an helpful but
luckily some supporters are taking to
Twitter doing their best to rebuild
Trump's ego
god bless the first retweet errs yes yes
David they've been working around the
clock that's for sure okay so for
everyone at home who wants to help what
can they do well we're asking people to
dig into their news feeds to donate
anything to help rebuild Trump
self-esteem so if you have anything to
offer things like Oh fawning Breitbart
articles electoral map showing all the
counties he won
or even child size gloves that are
labeled as adult size you have in your
pantry yeah thanks Laura stay safe out
there
we've got copula be in the studio Kobe
how do we move forward from this
national tragedy it's time we focus on
rebuilding trumps infrastructure Jordan
his critical support systems
he's lost Bannon scaramouche II Tom
Price so many voices that protected him
and kept his ego fortified as he looks
forward Trump is going to have to build
new emotional levees to keep all the
good feelings in yeah do you think that
Americans will keep Trump's ego in mind
not just now during the worst of the
fallout but far into the future it's
tough to say Jordan I think that lots of
people need to remember that just
because Trump's ego doesn't have a star
on the flag or isn't on any maps of the
country or doesn't pay federal income
tax it's still an American territory and
its massive Jordan s it sure is Kobe
lebih Laura gray thank you
[Music]